d'adhésion à l'OTAN.
(tirs)
- Camila n'avait pas prévu
passer les pererers jours
ensoleillés du printemps avec
une arme à la main, mais cette
vendeuse de fromage et jambon
dans un supermarché se dit
rassurée de pouvoir consacrer
le prochain mois à parfaire
le maniement des armes.
"C'est important, dit-elle,
parce que je veux faire quelque
chose au lieu de rester à la
maison et m'inquiéter de ne pas
savoir quoi fa c c c ce qui va
se passer."
Ce qui l'inquiète,
c'est la Russie.
Camila fait partie des
réservistes de la défense
territoriale de la Suède.
En temps normal, elle doit
consacrer quelques jours par
mois à l'entraînement, mais ça
ne suffit plus, a décidé son
pays.
"C'est tout près de chez nous
alors c'est devenu une réalité,
dit Jeannette. C'est inquiétant,
mais je n'ai pas peur."
Jeanette aussi est volontaire
et elle ne vient pas seule.
Ses deux chiennes entraînées
à la détection de dro
d'explosifs pourraient aussi se
porter à la défense de la Suède.
"Poutine a clairement montré
au monde qu'il est prêt à
utiliser la force militaire
pour atteindre ses objectifs
ququququques. Comme Gotland a ue
grande importance stratégique,
bien sûr qu'il faut se
préparer."
Magnus commande les forces du
régiment de Gorltetetetetemps de
la guerre froide, la Suède avait
déployé jusqu'à 25 000 de ses
soldats sur l'île.
Quand elle a pris fin, Gotland a
été comp d d d d d démilitarisé.
La Suède n'est pas le seul pays
d'Europe qui ait changé
d'approche et qui se soit
détournée de la Défense
nationale pour participer
à des opérations militaires
internationales, fait valoir
le commandant. Mais dans la
situation que nous vivons,
c'était une erreur.
Ce que le commandant qualifie
d'erreur a éé é é é é é en 2014,
après l'annexion de la Crimée
par la Russie. Aujourd'hui,
200 soldats de l'armée régulière
sont en poste à Gotland.
Ils seôôôôôôt beaucoup plus
nombreux.
Le gouvernement suédois
vient d'annoncer avoir mis
de côté 163 millions d'euros
supplémentaires, soit plus de
220 millions $, pour renforcer
ses infrastructures militaires
sur l'île.
Si Gotland, en plein coeur de
la mer Baltique, reçoit
aujourd'hui autant d'attention,
c'est qu'elle est située à
quelque 300 kilomètres de
l'enclave russe de Kaliningrad.
Et c'est de là que la Russie
pourrait bien mettre à exécution
ses menaces de riposte si la
Suède décidait de se joindre à
l'OTAN.
Au-delà des côtes du Gotland,
il est là, le débat qui émerge
à la surface pour la Suède
aujourd'hui. Tout comme la
Finlande voisine, le pays
scandinave a fait de
la non-adhésion à l'OTAN une
véritable doctrine pendant des
décennies. Mais le gouvernement
social-démocrate est sur le
point de rompre avec c
tradition de neutralité
militaire.
L'opinion publique suédoise
aussi a basculé de façon
importante depuis l'invasion
russe en Ukraine. Un Suédois
sur deux se dit aujourd'hui
en faveur, du jamais vu!
"D'abord, nous avons vu que
l'Ukraine n'était pas protégée
par l'OTAN. Nous avons compris
que nous ne le saurions sans
doute pas non plus. Nous avons
aussi vu que la menace était
réelle, pas que des paroles.
Et ensuite, nous avons vu les
provocations et les menaces de
la Russie depuis longtemps. Mais
elle est allée trop loin, alors
nous n'avons pas pris peur, nous
nous sommes fâchés",
explique-t-il.
Une colère que partage cette
députée suédoise au Parlement
européen. Il y a un mois, elle
foulait le sol de Boutcha, en
banlieue de Kiev. Elle en est
revenue hantée par les crimes
de guerre qui y ont été commis.
"Ce que nous avons vu à
Boutcha, dit-elle, la même chose
est en train de se reproduire
ailleurs en Ukraine,
pendant que nous sommes ici.
C'est très douloureux."
C'est ce qu'elle venue dire
à ce petit groupe de citoyens
s s s s s s s s s s ukrainiens
rassemblés au centre de
Stockholm par un samedi
pluvieux. Karin Karlsbro n'avait
cependant pas besoin de voir les
horreurs de la guerre en Ukraine
pour soutenir l'adhésion
pays à l'OTAN. Le Parti libéral,
dont elle est membre,
milite depuis longtemps en
faveur de l'alliance militaire.
"Maintenant, c'est urgent,
dit-elle e e e e e e e e e e en
Ukraine a réveillé la société
suédoise."
Si tous sont visiblement, comme
elle, bouleversés par le sort de
l'Ukraine, ils ne partagent pas
nécessairement son enthousiasme
pour l'OTAN.
Un peu à l'image des propos
des dirigeants suédois, Gillian
paraît plus résignée qu'emballée
à l'idée d'abandonner
la neutralité de la Suède.
Il le faut, dit-elle, mais c'est
le sacrifice d'un idéal.
"Il y a tant d'aspects que je
n'aime pas, mais j'ai peur pour
la Finlande aussi et je ne vais
pas l'abandonner si elle rejoint
l'OTAN
Le choix est douloureux pour
mbmbmbmbmbmbmbmbmbmbmbmble
aujourd'hui qu'il sera sans
surprise. La Suède doit annoncer
sa décision dimanche prochai